look great honey
what are you I'm a mouse duh Kendall
Jenner is proving she is cool as a
cucumber poking fun at this moment that
hat fans shook be careful because I
nicked myself the other day I don't know
I'm kind of scared I definitely am not a
good cutter so don't zoom in on me
for Halloween the model dressed up as
yes a cucumber spoofing that now a viral
moment from the Kardashians the perfect
accessory a fake kitchen knife and
playing in the background a scene from
Mean Girls Where Lindsay Lohan's
character says in girl world Halloween
is the one night a year when a girl can
dress like a total [ __ ] and no other
girls can say anything about it the
hardcore Girls just wear lingerie and
some form of animal ears but if it's
still unclear why Kendall dressed up as
a cucumber let us refresh your memory
do you want the chef to make you a snack
I'm making it myself just gotta chop up
some cucumber it's pretty easy go girl
in an episode of the Hulu series that
aired in May Kenny made a snack for
herself and showed off her culinary
skills or should we say lack thereof be
careful because I nipped myself the
other day I don't know I'm kind of
scared I definitely am not a good cutter
so don't zoom in on me
I'm not professional whatsoever
hey Chef do you want to cut this up for
her I'll do it mom is fine the
Kardashian Stars unconventional cucumber
slicing took the Internet by storm I
don't know if you guys saw this but the
model and reality star has gone viral
for a very bizarre culinary blunder yep
it even made The Today Show I've sliced
many a cucumber in my day I don't see
whether it's a different style what's
wrong with that I don't know she was
holding it people were enraged Kendall
quickly caught wind of all the chatter
and hopped online to respond she called
her kitchen skills simply tragic oh my
God she's like not happy about it I know
I could tell by her retweet that she
wrote tragic that she's being sarcastic
and that means she's kind of upset about
it yeah Kenny's big says Chloe revealed
the model took the Cucumber conundrum
kind of personal I mean we're normal
people we go through our normal like
emotional days or like heart rough days
like we're we're just like anyone else
but as Coco does she lifted Kenny
Spirits I feel so I'm like Kendall God
is fair you're the most beautiful human
being in the world you have wild looking
toes God bless and you can't cut a
[ __ ] cucumber the world is good
because she's like how can you be this
perfect she is the perfect life this
perfect dog she's a gazelle of a human
being yeah you can't cut a cucumber like
protein is the best sister I'm gonna
teach her how to cut a cucumber it's not
always easy fast forward to Halloween
and Kendall's not afraid to laugh it off
oh my God just be cool she's clearly
embracing all of life's hiccups one
slice at a time the hardcore Girls just
wear lingerie and some form of animals
[Music]
what are you
I'm a mouse duh